Netflix's adaptation of the travels and travails
of the mutated monster-hunter Geralt are based
on Andrzej Sapkowski's long-running series
of novels and short stories, and not on the
popular Witcher video game trilogy.
But the CD Projekt Red games are a massive
hit across the world, and the Witcher series'
writer and showrunner Lauren Schmidt Hissrich
knows it.
That's precisely why, as Hissrich began adapting
the high-fantasy world and laying out her
season 1 narrative, she was sure to leave
some room for an obvious nod or two to those
who entered the fabled world through their
consoles.
While Hissrich pulled several iconic monsters,
men, and moments from Sapkowski's expansive
novels, she made sure to slip in a bathing
scene between lovers Geralt of Rivia and mage
Yennefer that had become wildly popular among
fans of The Witcher 3: Wild Hunt.
"Fishing for a Djinn seems an extreme measure
to remedy sleeplessness."
"When extreme measures seem reasonable, yes.
I'm desperate."
The "bathtub Geralt" scene is featured during
the game's opening sequence and captures an
intimate, bare-all moment between the monster
slayer and his on-again-off-again partner
Yennefer.
By the looks of it, they've both somewhat
settled down with Geralt's charge, Princess
Ciri
At San Diego Comic-Con 2019, Hissrich first
alluded that some form of the scene would
appear on the Netflix show.
She told iO9:
"There is a bathtub this season.
There is a bathtub.
I won't tell you who's in the bathtub, but
there is a bathtub."
For those who were new to The Witcher universe
when the Netflix series first dropped, the
moment might have felt like one among many
gratuitous shirtless scenes, but it actually
holds a broader significance.
The "bathtub Geralt" scene opens The Witcher
3: Wild Hunt, and is somewhat beloved for,
of course, giving gamers a glimpse of Geralt
both in the nude and providing a rare, intimate
moment with the woman he loves.
Relaxing in a hot bath within his chamber
at the Witcher Academy known as Kaer Morhen
in the game Geralt is seen with his feet and
arms hanging over the sides of a wooden tub.
We then see him jolt up and remove a crustacean-like
creature from his, erm… private parts.
"You know I don't find that amusing."
It takes only a moment for it to become clear
the animal isn't real and is instead a magical
prodding delivered by the naked but strategically
positioned sorceress Yennefer.
Geralt promised Ciri he'd train with her,
and Yennefer wants him to get on with it,
so the moment ends with Geralt begrudgingly
exiting the tub, walking over to the mage,
and engaging in a passionate kiss before stomping
off to meet up with Ciri.
It's not particularly long and not especially
exciting, but it does offer up a different
side to the life of Geralt one where he doesn't
have to be all sword-wielding and blood splatter.
The scene's a slice-of-life moment that helps
flesh out The Witcher games' key characters.
The moment within the Netflix series is somewhat
different, with Geralt and Yennefer mostly
teasing one another as the issue around the
Djinn an air genie that causes chaos looms.
The sorceress even joins the monster slayer
of Rivia in the steaming hot soak.
But like The Witcher 3 sequence, it's mostly
about the verbal tit-for-tat Geralt and Yennefer
are known for.
The inclusion of the scene in the show was,
for showrunner Hissrich, a very intentional
olive branch for video game fans.
She told GamesRadar:
"It is fun to visually throw a wink and a
nod at video game fans, to say, 'We see you
too.
We know you're here.'
And we want them to be happy with what we're
doing as well."
While it's not clear if we'll get any more
steamy scenes featuring Geralt the bathing
beauty on the show's second season, season
one's bare-chested, peeking knee-cap action
will surely suffice in the meantime for gamers
and casual oglers alike.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.